hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
quantum gravity is a topic that we've
returned to again and again uh in part
because I think it's really interesting
it's part of what I do in my research
career but also because it's a great
example of Science in action or at least
theoretical physics in action
theoretical physics might not be
representative as a science but it's an
example of a science and we know that
there's quantum mechanics those are the
fundamental ways that the world works we
know there's gravity it exists so
somehow they need to be reconciled and
we're not sure how if you've read the
big picture you've heard me talk about
the laws of physics underlying everyday
life you know that we have enough idea
of how quantum gravity Works to explain
simple conditions like the solar system
why apples fall from trees but when
things get extreme in black holes or the
Big Bang we don't have the full Theory
so we don't know exactly what to say we
do have a set of rules for taking a
classical Theory like on Einstein's
general relativity and quantizing it but
those rules don't work for gravity or at
least not in any ordinary
straightforward way so by following
progress in quantum gravity you can kind
of see how science works when we don't
know the answer and also for that matter
when there's not a lot of detailed
experimental evidence there is
experimental evidence namely all of the
experiments that say that gravity is
real and all the experiments that say
the quantum mechanics is how the world
works but that's not a lot of guidance
when it comes to reconciling them and of
course we know that there's different
strategies for doing this Loop quantum
gravity is something that is still
popular the very second episode we ever
did of mindscape was Carlo rivelli who
talked a little bit about that but
string theory is by far the most popular
approach to quantum gravity for many
decades now and so today's guest Andy
strominger is one of the world's leading
theoretical physicists of any sort but
string theorist in particular and I
think it's a really great overview a
very really great interview because we
both get into some details about
specific questions in string theory and
quantum gravity but also you get to see
a little bit of the development of the
field Andy was there at the beginning of
string theory not the very very
beginning you know the ideas behind
String Theory stretch back to the 60s
and 70s but what what is called the
first Super string Revolution was in
1984 when Andy strominger was a young
scientist and he helped develop the idea
of compactifying 10-dimensional
space-time down to our four-dimensional
world in ways that make it look like the
physics we observe the standard model of
particle physics looked like vaguely
because we still don't know how to get
exactly the correct complete theory of
the standard model from String Theory
but the first huge step was taken by
Andy and his collaborators and since
then he's still been at the Forefront of
many different ideas we'll talk a lot in
this podcast about the work that he did
with komun Buffa who's also at Harvard
on figuring out why black holes have the
entropy they do in terms of the
microscopic states that you combine to
make a black hole in the context of
string theory those extremely
influential paper thousands of citations
but also the theme that I want to tease
out which is maybe not obvious to
someone who just reads Andy's CV and
looks at his papers where he has many
many very influential papers is that he
does keep his eyes on the prize he wants
to connect quantum gravity to the real
world so you might know that um well
let's let's just back up and put it in
context a little bit you know in the 60s
and 70s when people were doing String
Theory they were scattering strings kind
of like particle physics in the 80s this
idea of compactifying and looking at
different ways of getting String Theory
connected to four-dimensional physics
became popular in the 90s there was the
second and super string Revolution where
you realize that there were higher
dimensional D brains as well as strings
and of course the famous ads cfd
correspondence that we talked about
several times here on the podcast most
recently with Rafael Busa and in the ads
CFT correspondence you have a duality
that relates quantum gravity string
theory in particular in 10 dimensional
space-time compactified in a certain way
to Quantum field theory in
four-dimensional space-time so the point
of me running through this history is to
point out that the boundaries between
doing string theory and just doing
Quantum field Theory or theoretical
physics more generally have become
increasingly blurry that's why every
time we have a string theorist on the
podcast they are slightly reluctant to
call themselves a string theorist
because sometimes they're just doing
Quantum field Theory or dust gravity
Theory or whatever that's where we are
now but ads EFT is still
consuming a lot of oxygen in the quantum
gravity world and Andy has been one of
the best people in pushing Beyond ads
CFT to think about the sitter space Not
Just anti-disitter space a universe with
a positive vacuum energy like our real
world has and also to think about Out
The Duality or the holographic
description of black holes in our
universe and Andy is part of the black
hole initiative at Harvard where they
combine people who do theoretical
physics like Andy does with philosophers
and also experimentals and observers who
are actually looking at black holes with
the Event Horizon telescope and
elsewhere they're trying to figure out
how we can get data from black holes
that either just help us understand
classical gravity in black holes or
maybe string theory and quantum gravity
so that's why it's a it's an exciting
time it takes a long time to make
progress in these areas when you don't
have guidance from data but we're going
to get a master class here from one of
the people who are real is really on the
inside moving this field forward about
how to make progress in quantum gravity
and connect it to the real world so
let's go
[Music]
thank you
Andy's Real Madrid welcome to the
mindscape podcast glad to be here you
know it's great to have you on because I
was thinking about it we have done
quantum gravity string theory and things
like that before but we've had you know
Lenny suskind who was there at the very
prehistory of it all uh yeah he's had
the younger generation you know Rafael
buso Netta engelhardt uh Clifford
Johnson but you were sort of perfectly
timed right I mean your physics career
was just starting when super strings hit
the scene uh so I mean maybe tell us
that's right I hit I hit the Beatles
when I was in Adolescent and then I hit
super strengths when I was bored at the
right time very very anthropical at the
right time yes
I mean maybe we could just start by
giving your view uh uh be as personal as
you want about how quantum gravity
research has evolved over your own
research career
yeah well that's that's a really
interesting question so
um I started graduate school at uh near
the end of a a really strong uh you know
Heyday of of particle physics when you
know new results were coming out of
accelerators practically you know every
week and there was all kinds of
excitement
um the strong interactions as you know
the qcd is the theory of strong
interactions was
not even fully accepted uh when I was a
graduate student I had to defend it in
my thesis against wow at
experimentalists yeah it's kind of
surprising to think about now
um and there were you know two of the
really big problems uh that are really
you know ambitious graduate student
was
expected to try to tackle were you know
solving the strong interactions in some
way finding an analytic method to
compute the mass of the proton
um a problem which still uh remains
unsolved so basically progress
continues with uh very recently and the
other one was finding the grand unified
theory that was before people had become
discouraged by the absence of a proton
decay and other things too but those
were were two of the two of the big ones
but just uh just to help the audience in
in your in the as a term of art Grand
unified theory does not include gravity
it's not a Theory of Everything
gravity was so off of people's radar
screen right that the term Grand Unified
uh was unification of the elect of the
the weak uh the Electoral week uh and
the strong forces in one uh in one whole
and people did you know oh gravity who
cares about that you know
you know it's very strange very strange
but um
you know there was a small
group of people and by small in the
world
uh I mean dozens and
um who were interested in not so much
unifying gravity with the other forces
but just having a theory of it right
there work was a theory of the strong
and the electroweak interactions that uh
Nobel prizes were about to appear for
but there was no
theory of gravity that was consistent
with quantum mechanics
and the fact that there was a problem
you know these are arguably you know two
of the greatest achievements in the 20th
century physics the discovery of quantum
mechanics and the uncertainty principle
and Einstein's theory of general
relativity
and these two pillars of of physics uh
were uh at that time uh completely
incompatible no way of
writing them having them both on the
same piece of paper
no self-consistent way
of having them both on the same piece of
paper existed
and the number of people interested in
that problem was in in the dozens
and uh in Cambridge at that time I was a
grad student at
Berkeley and then I moved to MIT in
Cambridge in that time there were two or
three
people
discussing it
um
and it was
uh it's fair to say that it was heavily
discouraged and looked down on uh my
thesis advisor who I could quote because
he quoted myself told me not to work on
it I would never get a job and then
several decades later when I was giving
a colloquium at MIT he said he said he
told me that and then he added good
thing he didn't listen to me
and he wasn't the only one many many
people
um basically all the
all the influential uh leading figures
in the in the field were in the field of
theoretical physics felt it was a
problem that
um
first of all not very
interesting and secondly uh premature
that we didn't have any ways to address
it and
and also that it was very far from
having any possible uh contact with
experiment I don't know if you know the
story but Hugh Everett when he invented
the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics he was a grad student
at Princeton and John Wheeler was his
advisor and the thesis project he was
given was quantized gravity
but he couldn't figure out how to do
that but he realized that if you had the
whole universe as your Quantum system
there were no outside observers and that
led him to invent many worlds so there
was a good thing that came out of it
anyway yeah yeah yeah
well John Wheeler was certainly one of
the early champions of of
the importance of quantum gravity though
um
you know he has many
you know a Mythic figure and right 20th
century physics with many great
achievements uh
not least a month which is uh according
the word black hole and um
he worked on quantum gravity but like
many people who had worked on it in the
preceding
you know 20 30 years didn't have too
much to show for it right so I actually
I'll confess I did research for this
podcast I went on to inspire and went
through your publication list because I
was going to guess that you would have
been like many people in that era where
you were working on Quantum field Theory
or qcd or unification and then String
Theory came along and you jumped on it
but you were already doing clone of
gravity so you were coming at it from a
different direction a little bit I was I
was doing quantum gravity and
um
I
I wanted to that was my main interest
um throughout my thesis I you know I had
my day job which was qcd and so on I you
know it would seemed interesting you
know the interesting problem so it
wasn't where my my real passion lied
um
and um
I guess somewhere sometime around 19
83 yeah 1983 it would have been
I realized that
um
that string theory was the string
theorists of which there were really
it practiced only two at that time who
were really you know created Schwartz
that were running around talking about
it uh I mean other people had worked on
it but they were the uh
um
that they were claiming to have
a mathematical resolution
of the problem of quantum mechanics and
general relativity in other words they
were claiming
well all right let me back up they were
claiming to have solved the infinity
problem right which is the one that
um Wolfgang Pauley first noticed in the
1950s that you can't just
you know take out your cookbook and
dress up gravity with quantum mechanics
in the way that we did so incredibly
successfully for the electro week and
the strong interactions that somehow
gravity wasn't going to play by those
rules that was what
what Paulie noticed and then there's
also of course Hawking's problem
of black hole entropy and uh information
Lawson and so on which I imagine will
come to later I don't know
um conversation could go anywhere but um
so green and Schwartz were claiming to
have
solved the first problem in just an
existence proof of a theory which could
reduce to Einstein's theory of general
relativity in one limit and Heisenberg
Schrodinger
quantum mechanics in another
and that was no mean feat yeah we were
very clear however about the fact that
their Theory could not be the real world
because it didn't have quarks and
leptons and parity violation and all
those good things that we we have
observed and love and
um so
but they came from both of them a
particle physics
background
and the theory was
presented in a very particle physics
like language
and
um
I remember saying
just at the time I was trying to learn
strictly so I felt I had to learn it
because somebody claimed to have solved
the problem that I was working on
and
um
so I should understand what they were
saying fair enough
even if I was predisposed I was
predisposed not to like it because you
see my thought was that it was a very
deep and uh which it I still boobs
correct but it's a very deep problem and
it had resisted solution for decades and
we really needed some new
conceptual input like the equivalence
principle or the uncertainty principle
or some really fundamentally way
different way of and there that the main
hypothesis of string theory
that particles were are in fact little
strings in my then eyes fell short of
the deep you know it seemed a little uh
just kind of trivial and mathematical
and uh
and uh it fell short of what I was
looking for so I did really like it but
I felt obligated to to learn it
and I remember just coincidentally
around that time I I was at the
institute for a bit study that and Mike
Green visited for a week and they put
him in my office
and I I had some conversations with him
uh and I said to him I remember saying
to him
you know so I began to accept that it it
technically solved the problem but I
still didn't like it and I was trying to
find something wrong with it
and I remember saying to a
mic but isn't it just really ugly
[Laughter]
and my my God these kind of stars in his
eyes and went on something which I saw a
lot about later
you know about how beautiful it was and
it's one of those things that you really
um now of course we have far more
elegant they had the most
clumsy possible way of describing it and
presenting it Brute Force kind of shut
it brute force it just looked like a
pages of technical complicated formulas
and you get to the end and you find that
the affinities go away and you you feel
kind of swindled I feel like if
something something so simple is
happening why can't we you know
understand it
something so profound is happening why
do we need all these pages of pages of
equations I you know I had slaved
through their monographs of light code
formulation of the street bearing and I
I didn't like it of course you know
um
obviously I turned around on it and in
due course I began to see it oftens
happens in physics that
people who get really
totally a thousand percent immersed in a
subject began to see a kind of beauty
and Inner Harmony in a set of equations
that other people from the outside can't
see and it's easy to be critical of
those people thinking they're just lost
in their equations but I I think it's I
have great respect for these people who
just calculated don't it takes all kinds
to do things it takes all kinds
absolutely we need those we need those
people yeah that dive in calculate
and just to sort of feel really get to
the bones of something and you know Mike
and John had been doing that for 10
years and they saw something that really
nobody else nobody else did and and uh
yeah and when you did there's some other
people too there's other people yeah
yeah but but when you did dive in one of
the first things you did was to help
explain how it might be related to the
real world we don't want to leave that
thing you said Hanging that it's it
can't be the real world we know better
now that's right and so
um
I I had been
right I had been trying to understand
how
um you know Calusa Klein theory of
course which Einstein was his spent the
last half of his life on trying to unify
the forces using extra Dimensions that
was very beautiful and compelling and
um and so and green and Schwartz it
didn't didn't put geometry in
um it was all scattering of gravitons
with other particles
so we we put the geometry
back in
and
um we we found as you just alluded to we
found that if you look very carefully at
the equations of string theory and 10
dimensions and consistent ways to get
rid of the ten dimensions and get down
to four
that
um just the simplest
thing which involved actually
it was the simplest thing but it did
involve a lot of very deep mathematics
the globby conjecture yeah I was proof
of the Colombia conjecture some ideas in
algebraic geometry but nevertheless it
was just it sort of popped out of a hat
that when you
look through this carefully and you look
at exactly how String Theory allows the
extra Dimensions to curl up so that we
can't see them
it very naturally results not only in a
parody violating structure like the one
in our world with plenty of room for you
know all the leptons and quarks and and
and all of that but the natural unified
gauge groups were sort of the only thing
that you could get so when we did that I
I it was a feeling like
um
you know sort of throwing a basketball
from the far end of the court and having
it big into the hoop yeah and and the
world you know the world resonated with
that I mean within a few months after
our paper the number of people working
on string theory went from
from dozens to
you know a thousand or something like
that I haven't seen anything uh else
like that in my my career that was sure
fun to be
um to be to be
um right right at the right at the
center of that yeah and I get the
impression as someone who is string
theory positive but not involved with it
myself that these days most of the
people in the field are more on the
geometry side than the particle physics
side like the questions that are
involving our minds or maybe they're
just the questions I'm paying attention
to do have a lot to do with gravity as
gravity less so with particle physics as
particle physics
absolutely absolutely
um the but but that took the thousand
people who oddly the thousand people who
started working on it
after we showed this were the people
were mostly the particle physics people
who had been trying to understand
unification
and
um you know they were
you know string theory was in my view
and uh
wrongly viewed as kind of the the final
Capstone and the reductionist program of
of physics and
um that was what got them excited there
was less of a reaction from the general
relativity Community where most of the
people who had been working
on the problem of quantum gravity
circulated right so the people who had
been working on that problem oddly
didn't Embrace String Theory uh as a
as a solution though at that time though
everything you know everything shakes
itself out the fullness of time but yeah
and and at this point just to you know
jump right up to the present day
um well we're still thinking very very
broadly here give me your impression of
how you think about String Theory like
you've already hinted by tone of voice
that maybe it is not the completion of
the reductionist program of Everything
Is it is it something that teaches us
things and a useful thing to think about
for the moment or are you really
conceptualizing it as an 80 chance of
being just the final answer to physics
okay so
um
yeah so after having thrown the ball or
come across the the court
uh it got into the got into the hoop you
know if we did that once more
uh we'd have that would be it yeah you
know but we didn't do it once more right
and nothing that
exciting in the
um
in the
goal to make direct kind of experimental
contact with reality
I don't think happened again
and
um
and I rather quickly I mean the the
problem was that there
were many ways to curl up
the extra dimensions and that led to a
sort of proliferation
of it's sort of there's a a sense in
which string theory
uh is unique but I as I would put it
there's so many phases of it that
there's no real predictive power there
and I
any other people
who the Press was less interested in
quoting I took the point of view that
string theory was not going to make an
experimental prediction I wrote that
already in 1986 a year after my my my
paper on the and was not this kind of
the next step in the reductionist
program
and so you know it's disappointing of
course that we haven't
been able to make contact with
experiment
um there's a basic problem that the
basic scale and size of the phenomena
that we're looking at where quantum
mechanics and gravity are both important
is 10 to the minus
33 centimeters which is unimaginably
small and we're really
you know it could happen
that some these experimentalists are
blowing our minds and our socks off
every week it could happen that they
come up with something amazing but this
would be even more amazing you know so
I'm not expecting that
and that's disappointing but I think
what has happened
is
more wonderful and more exciting than
anything we imagined
in 1984 1985.
in the sense that we've gotten
um
you know
ideas about you know how space and time
might emerge from uh you know the
holographic principle and so maybe we'll
get into that later maybe we won't but
what has happened is you know you know
teasers and inklings of how different
the universe might be than than what we
um
than what we
imagine in what our senses you know tell
us it it it it's like the analogy I like
to use so if you ask me about
percentages I would say the chance
people often ask the question is string
theory right or is it wrong in the sense
of describing the real world
it's it's not a yes or no question
and
um
I think the chances of it being a
hundred percent right
in other words that we
we find the right collabio space and
that we
nothing needs to be added to what we
said in 1985 except finding the right
Columbia outspace and you know finding
out of the condescence work or whatever
you know
um
I think the chances of that of it really
in the end being the solution of the
reductionist Paradigm as
was momentarily hoped in the 80s you
know our I don't know wanted a billion
wanted a billion and zero essentially
yeah okay
but I think that the chances of it being
completely wrong and irrelevant that a
hundred years from now
historians of science will look at this
is an amazing prolonged detour on our
path to the truth of about about nature
are even smaller
an analogy I would like to use is Yang
Mills Theory okay so the egg Mills
theory is a very famous Theory
discovered by Jaeger bills in the 50s
everybody every physicist knows about it
they invented it
to describe the relationship between the
proton and the neutron
that turned out to be completely Raw
but it had a kind of inner consistency
in a structure and it kept bouncing back
and appearing everywhere
and now we realize well it doesn't
describe the proton and a neutron it
describes everything else in a more
fundamental level except gravity yeah
um so I think that
String Theory you know where we tend to
be too arrogant about how complete our
current knowledge is
I think they're going to be fundamental
new ideas and ways of looking at things
and we've already seen that
within happen within String Theory many
times and I think it will continue to
happen and that somehow String Theory
will find its place but not in the
simple way that we imagined and it may
how much it will look
you know String Theory today is such a
different Theory than the one green and
you know green and Schwartz
presented to us and you know in the 80s
um
uh and it will grow and accrete other
things and be connected to other things
in in many ways before it it finds its
home and
some kind of home and physical reality
that's that's my guess and I think that
makes perfect sense and and one of the
things that we have learned by doing
string theory is of course holography
that you already mentioned the ads CFT
correspondence we've talked about ads
safety a couple times on the podcast
with Raphael with Neda engelhardt
um but I wanted to see ask if you know
you could explain it in your words and
then move on to you've been one of the
leaders trying to bring it closer to the
real world because we do not have an
anti-decider background in which we live
we don't have a negative cosmological
constant maybe we could connect you to
something with a more realistic positive
cosmological constant
yeah I would frame it this way
I would go back to beckenstein and
Hawking
and the whole graphic principle
so
beckenstein and Hawking showed using as
stunningly simple and elegant argument
um that the
number of gigabytes in a black hole
number of gigabytes of information that
a black hole can store
is proportional to its area
and that is very very strange because
the number of gigabytes you could put in
your phone and on your hard drive is
proportional to the volume in your phone
you know you stack the chips up in there
and you this fixed amount of volume for
each one
so it's very very strange that the
number of gigabytes should go like the
area
um
so now we have these giant black holes
that we see in the sky and it suggests
that there's you can only store the
information or it's sufficient to store
the information
by putting the chips just on the surface
The Horizon of the black hole now you
can't really do that because they would
just fall in nothing would keep them
there right and there's no it's very
hard to see exactly how that will happen
but that is what happens in a hologram
in a holographic play you can store all
the information on the surface of the
region you're trying to describe
so I would call this the first
um the word did holographic principle
didn't uh exist then but this was the
first uh
version of it and then it twofton suskin
uh
recognized how what a poor idea this was
they they talked about it they had some
uh important discussions of it but
nothing really took hold or became
precise
and then what happened in string theory
again in string theory we've we've found
um and this is what vafa and I did we
literally using
a crazy complicated so often happens in
physics that you you have uh some really
complicated argument to derive something
and then over time it gets simpler and
simpler and simpler
and you realize you didn't need all that
complicated stuff
but we found a very complicated uh
Construction
within string theory of special kinds of
stringy black holes that do have a vent
Horizons and they do they are subject to
the beckenstein Hawking analysis which
says that their
um gigabyte capacity should be
proportional their area area
and vafa and I actually constructed the
hologram
in complete
um
complete detail and it involved the
kitchen sink you know we we had all
kinds of mathematics it was it was
completely correct and we hit the answer
on the notes
um but it was very complicated
and uh but it was an existence proof
that you of the holographic
principle we realized how a region of
space-time a black hole
the black hole being the Hologram could
be realized by a holographic plate
this was then
um
generalized to
uh
whole universes which were really near
Verizon regions of of the of the black
hole
um
negatively curved uh
negatively curved
universes
and
um and
maldicena
formulated a very precise conjecture
which applied to these negatively curved
universes in
specific examples that occur within uh
String Theory
um
and up to I guess seven dimensions and
um
showed again
concrete realizations within the
framework of string theory of uh of the
holographic principle
and again these
um
these constructions have a lot of
precise
mathematics in them
and as you know there have been
thousands or maybe tens of thousands of
papers working out details of this
generalizations of this enormous amounts
have been learned about mathematics
uh pure mathematics also properties of
physical
um systems it's been a great source of
kind of inspiration of how uh Quantum
systems
um
might be related to one another
but it's not the real world
and the real world uh in one
approximation in a very good
approximation it's flat it's not
negatively curved like these space times
and if you're a little more careful it
at least in the far future it's expected
that it's positively curved just the
opposite the center space rather than
anti-decider space so of the three
possibilities negative curvature zero
curvature and positive curvature the one
that we've understood is the least is
the furthest from physical
observable physical reality right so
it's been
um surprisingly uh difficult
to to generalize this
um to to those to those contexts
and is there a way at this level of
discussion or maybe we need to fill in
some more details but is there a way to
explain why it's so difficult I mean
shouldn't the real world be the easier
one to explain given our great
experience with it than the fake
negatively curved world
um
yeah that's a real really deep question
uh Sean um
well
you know I kind of suspect that when we
sometimes you don't always understand
the simplest things first there's still
hope
it could well be and you know
it could well be that
when we do understand the right way to
think about
the kind of geometries the holographic
principle in in the real world
um
that will kick ourselves
and and it will seem much simpler right
than whatever we were doing in
in anti-disitter space that could easily
happen
um
but also you know
the real world
is a very very complicated place a lot
of stuff happens
and now complexity of course can arise
out of Simplicity and often does
but to see through we're looking at the
end product to three see through this
very very complicated end product to
some simple structure is is uh you know
well it's super fun but you know it's
not easy and we haven't
we haven't succeeded yet and so we often
um whenever we find
some kind of every you know single
of uh physicists where they can make
some kind of simplify assumptions you
know Newton just talked about you know
planets moving in empty space and
treated the sun like a point-like mass
and you know he didn't take into account
all the magnetic fields of course he
didn't know about them but you know
um so we always make simplifying
assumptions and sometimes we study
theories with
um
simpler systems like
an age-old trick
already I was using it my PhD thesis to
study
Quantum chromodynamics you if you can't
do it in four dimensions four space time
Dimensions go down to two so that's
that's a way to simplify things
there's another way to simplify things
which is to have more symmetries
um you know and there's a very powerful
symmetry known as supersymmetry
that people use to simplify things and
gives you ways of calculating things
that that you you couldn't otherwise
let me
let me let me run something by you I'm
going to invoke my privilege as the
podcast host to be a little bit
technical hoping that the audience will
stay with us and we can back up a little
bit let's hope I can stay with you yeah
ads CFT anti-decider space conformal
field Theory Theory with gravity Theory
without gravity in one lower Dimension
uh one of the reasons why it works so
well is because the non-gravitational
side is a field Theory a Quantum field
Theory it lives in a space-time and has
an infinite number of degrees of freedom
Hilbert space Etc one of the ways in
which desitter space which you mentioned
the more realistic uh cosmology is
different is that it sort of boundary is
not to the left or right but in the
future or in the past and that's a
little weird but the other way is that
within a decider Horizon there's a
finite number of degrees of freedom
there's a finite dimensional Hilbert
space that characterizes it so is is
maybe one of the things that is well
maybe maybe I think so that's why I said
I'm gonna I'm gonna you know I agree
with you most people would agree with
you but we don't have I don't know for
sure we don't have a solid calculation
to back that but is there a a potential
idea that just we're better at Quantum
field Theory than we are at finite
dimensional models and and therefore the
thing that might be the Dual description
of the sitter space is not in our
toolkit already and that's slowing us
down
um
I mean it could be uh you don't you
you don't solve it until you
you know it's it's not over till the fat
lady sings I mean we don't know what we
don't know how what what the final
thing is is going to look like but I I
think the basic
problem
that people have wrestled with what the
problem you say is a
that is a very vexing one but it's it's
not the only vexing one fair enough yes
and there's another vexing one
which is that the whole basic idea of a
hologram
is something which sits at a boundary
you know it's the boundary of the black
hole and anti-decider space uh very
conveniently if you go out to large
radius has a boundary so it's you know I
often describe it as you know like a
like a can of soup you know you've got
the soup at the inside and then you got
the can and the
the can is the holographic plate tells
you what the ingredients are and the
soup is the is the space time that that
we live in now the sitter space if you
fix a moment of time and
start moving off in space eventually
you'll come back right to where you are
it doesn't have a boundary
in space it has a boundary in time
at the infinite future
so if you try to
invoke the holographic principle that
the holographic plate lives at the
boundary
the boundary has no time the boundary is
at the infinite future of time
and so this is like so so
um
you know so this is like the ultimate
sort of brain teaser you know how do you
how do we we don't have a boundary in
space we want to have a holographic
plate it's supposed to the holographic
plate is supposed to keep
have all the same information
as the Hologram the image but the image
has time in it the boundary doesn't how
do we put all these things it's you know
it's just we haven't solved it but it is
such just such a beautiful
uh conceptual problem and and you know
it's really
it's really wonderful in this subject to
be able to go back and forth between
things like the anti-decider the ads CFT
correspondence where you can write out
all the equations
until you're blue in the face and then
try to mesh that with these deep
conceptual
you know reframings that we're really
going to need if we're gonna take the
lessons that we've learned from
anti-decider space
separate the general features of the ads
CFT correspondence from the specific
ones that are associated with string
theory it's kind of you know sort of
take the meat off the bones
and and import it and use those insights
to say things about the real world that
we can you know say without in ever
invoking String Theory even if we got
trade by string theory on how to
understand these systems in the end we
don't we don't want to we don't want to
invoke it and that's true for desired
space it's also true for flat space that
it it is not it doesn't have its
boundary also doesn't have a simple time
that you can identify with flat space
actually of all of them has the funniest
bone right yeah
right you can buy my book you can buy
space time and geometry if you want to
be more you can buy your book it's a
great book that's I use it when I teach
the course on general relativity oh good
thank you
um so okay I just want to you know get
the footnote on the record that I my
guess is that the finite dimensionality
of hilver space is going to play a
bigger role once we do understand this
then a lot absolutely yeah yeah um but
you but all these things that you
mentioned do lead very naturally you
know the next thing I wanted to ask you
about is which is the Cur CFT
correspondence uh the idea that rather
than looking at a whole uh cosmology we
can think about individual black holes
um and relate them to a dual Quantum
field Theory and I think I've just
reached the limits of my knowledge there
but maybe you can fill in what the story
is
well okay so
um one of oh so that was sort of an
early uh
an early attempt which is still you know
looking very promising of uh trying to
take lessons from string theory and
apply it to the real world
so in this work with
um vafo where I says we use the kitchen
sink and algebraic geometry textbook and
everything to construct this
um holographic to construct the
holographic plate for these black holes
in string theory
as time went by
we found simpler and simpler ways of
doing the calculation
until finally we realized that there was
only one thing that mattered
and
the thing that mattered was what we call
an emergent symmetry
and that is sometimes there can be
regions of of space-time uh in which or
even emergent symmetries occur all over
the place
um like for example if you take uh I
guess the first example of it was
measured or one of the first measured
examples was sort of at the end of the
19th century the the so-called critical
opalescence in the liquid to gas phase
transition and carbon in other words we
take carbon at just the right uh
pressure and temperature it goes from
being a liquid to being a gas
all of a sudden it becomes opaque
right at that moment very noticeable
uh thing and that's because at that
point
it suddenly gets extra symmetries
so-called conformal symmetries
and that enables produces excitations
which can absorb the light you can't
can't see through it anymore
so there are many examples of this it's
this kind of critical phenomena and
emerging symmetries is really the
organizing principle of much of modern
physics from condensed matter to
particle physics to everything
and they're also examples of it and
astronomy they're they're fewer and
further in between but I think as time
goes on we'll be seeing more of them
and but of course a well-known one is
um the theory of an inflation where the
spectrum of the CMB fluctuations
suggests that various other evidence
suggests that the very early Universe
there were emergent uh the sitter
symmetries and there's even experimental
evidence for that
now
um so what
part of what vafa and I did was to show
that very near the Horizon of a black
hole
you got an emergent Symmetry and not
just a few of them but an infinite
number of them
could emergent conformal symmetries
and when you have and and there are
other examples in physics where this has
been experimented like in the quantum
hall effect you get you have emergent
many examples actually of infinitely
many emergent conformal symmetries and
when you have these infinitely many
um you have a lot of control
over the Dynamics of the system and in
fact there are Universal formulas that
you can drive
for systems with these infinite uh
numbers of symmetries that tell you
uh how many
gigabytes of information they can store
it's some excitation level
so weirdly this infinite
conformal symmetry was exactly what the
doctor ordered for uh
for answering this question posed by
implicitly posed by beckenstein and
Hawking back in the 70s how do we
explain
this uh you know this the the gigabytes
in a black the area law for the
gigabytes
in a black hole
now wonderfully
there aren't you know when we look up at
the sky at you know Jrs 1915 or m87 or
Sanjay star these are not very like the
black holes that
um
that Waffle and I
considered however
GRS however it turns out that black
holes
in some cases the ones we see in the
black hole up in the sky particularly
the very rapidly rotating ones black
holes can spin around they're called
curb black hole and every black hole we
see is spinning to a greater or lesser
degree they don't stay still yeah
and a surprising number of them
are spinning very rapidly they like to
spin rapidly if you throw something at
them if they interact with stuff it's
they tend to spin up okay
however there's a speed limit on black
holes and the speed limit is that the
surface of the black hole the so-called
venturizing is not allowed to spin
around faster than the speed of light
that's basically Einstein's speed limit
and uh when they get very near the speed
limit
um as they like to do they get exactly
the same
uh
uh conformal symmetry that vafa and I
used
to construct the Hologram for the
stringy black holes
and indeed you know cygnus X1 I think is
98 99 you know within one percent of the
speed limit Jairus 1915 maybe two
percent there's a lot of them that are
really really whizzing around up there
so these are black holes that you could
apply some
you could take some of the extracted
wisdom wisdom from our our stringy
adventures and use the same kind of
reasoning to understand
and explain their their
um
their their structure and
um
so so so that's a
that's an example of that's what you
call we're calling the Cur CFT uh
correspondence and the C there is
conformal field Theory so the conformal
is the conformal Symmetry and the Cur is
the curb black hole occurs the person
who found uh the spinning uh black black
hole solution
and
um
yeah the Symmetry also like the
fluctuations in the CMB and so on uh the
scale
the scale dependence of the CMB
fluctuations the Symmetry also has uh
predictions uh which which we've
which we've uh made for the structure of
emissions from and signals from you know
astrophysical uh black holes I think
it'll be sometime before we get to the
level of precision that that any of
these predictions could be could be
verified but uh we're we're we're we're
we're getting closer than vafa and I
were I mean that was extremely excellent
uh explanation there's just two little
things I want to fill in uh the word
conformal we've been throwing around a
lot is it is it good enough to think
about that as a scaling symmetry like
you zoom in twice as much and the system
looks the same as it did at your
original Zoom
exactly yeah okay good so that's that's
all conformal means it's not as scary as
it said things look the same on on all
different length scales uh you know
maybe the example people would be most
familiar with would be like a fractal
pattern you look at it you zoom in on
your screen it looks the same uh uh
yeah and the other thing I I think it's
maybe worth just teasing out a little
bit more of the your work with vafa and
its relationship here I mean there you
did like you said you did a lot of
kitchen sink stuff but the ultimate
system was was investigatable because
you had so much symmetry it was just
like there's a speed limit to the black
hole rotating there's also a certain
amount of charge you can put in a black
hole and and am I right to say that you
looked at that limit in a certain number
of Dimensions with supersymmetry and
everything
that's right that's right we looked at
the limit it right
um I mean when vafa and I uh
started the project uh we we didn't have
the idea that we were going to find this
conformal symmetry um
and we just kept at some point
um
you know we had learned so much
um you know particularly from
developments in the mid 90s and so on
but we could calculate so much of the
string theory
um that we thought you know this
calculation just has to be doable
um and we just kind of in the stupidest
possible way sat down looking at every
action which was it was over a period of
years discussing with many different
people who we tried all kinds of things
and eventually we got something
and at first it was a puzzle why we
we didn't understand that we the the
conformal Symmetry was enabling us to
calculate things
if you pick the wrong example it won't
have the conformal Symmetry and you'll
just get stuck yeah and so what happened
was in this case we didn't get stuck and
it was only retroactively that we
understood that it was because of the
conformal Symmetry that we we didn't we
didn't get stuck yeah good and that
even though it wasn't what you had in
mind that ended up helping you when you
wanted to think about more realistic
black holes in the universe because even
though they're not electrically charged
they're spinning so fast that something
almost as good happens yeah
and
um I don't know if you know this so that
we've sort of talked now about things
from the mid 90s from things from you
know late 2000s and so on so uh
very recently the last few years you
know so conformal symmetry keeps popping
up right you know it is our friend we're
always happy when we when we see it
because you know
um so you know it's popped up again
uh but this time in a way that is of
Interest
both to
um observational astronomers and
observational astronomers trying to
focus in on what they can learn and see
with particular well both the Event
Horizon telescope and to lesser degree
ligo what what what you can learn about
black holes by by measuring them
both to those people and to
um
theoretical physicists trying to
understand the whole graphic principle
and the mysteries of quantum black holes
and that's this business of the photon
Ray
um secretly this is what we've been
building up to intentionally the whole
conversation exactly where we want again
[Laughter]
and the provocative statement like this
is relevant to Observation so like in
the 80s we might have guessed that the
way String Theory would connect
observation was it would predict the
mass of all the particles that we see at
our our accelerators and now we know
that's going to be harder than we
thought but maybe maybe in retrospect
this should have been investigated
earlier but maybe the gravitational
lessons of string theory are going to be
helpful to observers
uh yes and and
um already I think that this you know
this um
this discovery of the beautiful and
observable
properties of the photon ring came out
of you know and it the discovery of
those properties although they will
follow from general relativity
um came out the way of looking at it
came out of string theory and
um you know things we would think about
uh in string theory and they are
definitely having a profound
um a profound influence on the
astronomers and I it is
one of the if not the main goals of the
future development of the Event Horizon
telescope of which I'm now a member oh
my God
yeah
um you know to to measure them
um
and uh so it's interesting for many
different uh points of view so what is
the photon ring we haven't told the
audience that yet yeah we entered okay
so
um
it turns out that a black hole if you
look at it is like a hole of mirrors
so if you shine a light on your face
bounce off your face the photon could go
off head towards the black hole it goes
straight to the black hole or just fall
in
but if it just misses it it'll Boomerang
around the back
and come back to you and you'll see
yourself
reflected around the side of the you'll
see and literally see an image of
yourself on the side of the black hole
but other things can happen
it can go and Boomerang and wrap around
the black hole once and then come
so you'll actually see an infinite
number of images of yourself if you you
know had perfect resolution while
looking at a black hole so it's like
it's like the Hall of Mirrors it's like
that if you go in a department store
with the three frames of a mirror trying
on some clothes you can see it should a
number of copies yourself a black hole
is like that but all the images Converge
on one place
and it turns out that a photon if you
aim it perfectly
will start to wrap around the black hole
we'll just keep wrapping around forever
just orbit the black hole forever and
never come back it fits perfectly
that's the photon ring
and that Photon ring
um
is if you look at the image
of a black so we haven't seen it yet uh
we've seen
in those in that famous donut picture
which most of your listeners have a
doubtedly seen that is not the photon
array that is light directly coming from
hot matter swirling around the black
hole directly to the to the telescope
um
uh but there are going to be finer
images
where the photons from that hot swirling
disc have wound around the black hole
and
um
and the whole series of of images and
that is what uh
we hope to observe uh these finer and
finer images
now this is extremely interesting for
um you know for understanding and
measuring the laws of physics because we
don't know much about what that swirling
disc is made of
and we don't know what kind of magnetic
fields are in there we don't know how
fast it's going and as we measure the
image uh better and better
will mostly be learning more about the
makeup of the matter swirling
around the black hole but what we really
want to learn about is the black hole
itself what we you and I do
well I think I think the uh you and I do
many things are many things are
interesting but certainly the the
the members of The Event Horizon
telescope are very keen to
to learn you know to see properties of
curved space-time we've inferred the
existence of Highly curved space-time
and black holes
so on
um but our our ways of directly probing
it are precious few right and seeing
something like a photon that is Rock
wrapped around the black hole at the
speed of light that is really a
qualitatively new observation
now what you're seeing so the black hole
is the mirror
here
and if you go to the department store
and you look at uh
at the direct image you might learn
about whether or not you want to buy the
clothes you're trying on but you won't
learn much about the structure of the
mirrors but if you look at the
relationship between the direct image of
the mirror and the once reflected that's
what you can from that totally it
doesn't matter what you're wearing
you'll get the same information about
the arrangement of the mirrors
so it factors out the relative images it
factors out all the uninteresting
information about
uh about the clothes you're wearing you
and your fashion sense yeah and and you
get all the information about about the
mirrors so that's what we want to do
um that's what we want to do with
with the with the black hole
and now uh and it turns out that this is
all possible
because of a conformal symmetry that
appears at the photon ring and in this
and in this context the conformal
Symmetry relates photons which uh wide
once to those that want twice
and and so on and in fact
if you dial this back to a
black hole that's rotating at the speed
limit
it's
kind of the same conformal symmetry so
they're not very far
they're not very far apart
and
um you know okay so
we have some ideas of how to apply to
the holographic principle to uh
uh black holes spinning at the speed
limit
so this Photon ring has been interesting
both through as I said to observers and
to theorists and there's nothing like
looking at an image to make you think
about things differently yeah it's been
amazing it's so true yeah it's looking
at an image makes you think differently
another thing that makes you think
differently is trying to explain
something
to observers
or to answer their questions you know
because basically
a little bit of a side but basically
and you know this shot
theoretical physicists are by and large
all really stupid and what we all do is
we rewrite with a few different words
the paper we wrote last week which is a
rewriting of somebody basically if you
could just think about things a little
bit differently that's huge just a
little bit different perspective is is
is enormous and observers are great for
asking you a question that makes you
that makes you think about things
differently
so we were looking at this and I invite
you to
look at that
last few seconds of the beautiful
numeric well I invite all your listeners
to look at the numerical simulation with
the stars of the background of
the first ligo merger look at the last
few seconds okay and then ask yourself
where is the holographic play hmm
well there's a little circle around
those black holes
that seems when you look at it that
circle is say I am the holographic play
I will look that up now there's no
mathematics here there's no mathematics
we're trying to get some mathematics but
but
the hypothesis is on the table
that the photon ring is actually
uh uh the holographic play and the best
evidence for that hypothesis
is just looking at it
but invite all your listeners to go dig
up that that video it's beautiful but
that's fascinating because I think that
most
people even physicists would have
guessed that all the holographies going
on at the Event Horizon of the black
hole and the photo exactly is quite a
bit separate from that that's right
that's right
though in ads CFT would be at the
boundary yeah yeah okay and and but
but you know I was I was would have said
what you just said
but there's no sort of proof of that and
it
and
go look at it okay yeah I want to look
at it now
tell me what if you're convinced you
don't even have to read our papers
about it just look at the picture I will
I absolutely will but I do want to ask
just again for clarity
um we're not saying here that string
theory is making a different prediction
than classical general relativity would
for these phenomena we're using string
theory to analyze a prediction that is
the same as we would ordinarily expect
is that right yeah we're not even using
string theory okay so
it's like this so before my construction
with Rafa nobody even had the foggiest
idea how it could possibly be that you
would have uh that number of gigabytes
in a black hole there was no
there was just no way to and it seemed
like really irreconcilable
uh
uh points of view the sort of general
relativity point of view and the
particle physics point of view seemed
seemed irreconcilable and the argument
however the argument
that they're irreconcilable had a series
of loopholes which which string theory
brilliantly snaked its way through
so now we know that there's there's a
route through that seeming paradox
and it would be it was a
nobody thought of the route before sort
of the stupid Brute Force calculation
revealed where it lied
and
now it would be surprising if there's
another route
in any case
it's worthwhile seeing if we can show
just starting with assuming quantum
mechanics general relativity
and many other things that we've come to
understand about
that we've come to show you know without
assuming String Theory or anything else
about the nature of quantum systems
involving gravity that that is that a
similar route is is followed by the real
world
but even a sketching of that route
for black holes that are way below this
spinning speed limit uh
has
has been missing we don't even have that
and we'd like to sketch how that route
could work and
looks to be like the photon rig is is is
a is a step on that route yeah okay well
you know yeah no we have to make
judgments haven't shown anything right
but I I you know I'm excited about
trying to understand this do you think
there is any hope
um for finding anywhere in the universe
um a deviation from classical general
relativity because of string theory
whether it's black holes or the
microwave background or something
weirder
they're certainly hope
um
but
um you know there's things that have
happened
like for example there was a moment when
it looked like there was a string up in
the sky that was lensing stars and that
might have been some kind of
uh evidence for string theory now that
disappeared that signal disappeared
but you know that's a nice existence
proof bicep two that was a wrong
experiment but it looked like we were
measuring Quantum gravitational effects
so it's not it's not logically
impossible
but uh I and I'm glad that there's a lot
of people out there who are vigorously
you know
shaking the trees trying to find some
way of of making the measurements but my
guess is they're you know
my guess it's I mean it's very important
that those people are doing that my
guess is they won't succeed you know it
until I mean science changes they won't
succeed you know we can't say what we
have no idea what science will look like
in say 20 30 years you know
but I don't think anybody will succeed
in the next 20 30 years after that old
bets are wrong we hope we're wrong right
what we hope we're wrong
of course I hope I'm wrong and I I and I
don't I don't want to be discouraging to
those people who are trying to do it
because I'd like them
I'd like them to continue but every
every scientist has to batch or uh
science is not a science it's an art a
gamble or whatever
um you know on on what things are likely
to pan out and and also what things they
each scientist feels they are good at
you know and so
um
I think that this kind of
understanding you know I spent
sort of the first 15 years of my career
as a theoretical physicists most of it
on top down assuming
assuming
what can we you know we had one example
of a theory that is consistent
with general relativity and quantum
mechanics what are the details of this
what is its structure and but for the
last that's top down physics you start
with some assumptions about microphysics
and you try to push them down but
there's a lot to do we're not short of
ideas on bottom up there's a lot to do
and the top-down approach
um has given us ideas on what to uh how
to proceed how to organize the bottom-up
approach and we need to do everything
I'm sure that we won't we won't get to
the I don't think we'll ever get to the
final truth of nature but I don't think
we'll even get to the big Next Step
without
doing everything using every approach
turning over every stone that's our job
you know that would be the perfect place
to end but I wanted to end uh with an
anecdote I mean that's a very
inspirational uh last place to go but
you probably don't remember but I this
might have been the first time we ever
met you came to MIT to give a seminar
back when I was either a grad student or
postdoc there uh we went out to dinner
afterward with a bunch of people
including Roman Jacob who was a
co-author on my first ever paper as well
as your thesis advisor and uh yeah we
were just chit chatting and there were
no string theorists in the audience
there except you because MIT didn't
really do String Theory at the time
um and at some point you mentioned you
said you know obviously each of us
thinks that whatever we're working on
right now is the most important thing to
be working on in all of physics and the
rest of the table sort of looked
uncomfortable and then you said well I
think that anyway
so do you still stand by that statement
and you think that's good advice
I stared by it yeah
it's a high bar it's you know it's easy
to do things in physics because we can
do them not necessarily because they're
the most important thing to be done
oh no but come on but it's part of the
statement right I mean I I wasn't trying
to
uh
you know it's a it's a knife edge there
there are things that are uh
you can do but they're not interesting
and then there's things that are
interesting but you can't do and things
which you can do are interesting that's
a knife edge and the Art of being a good
physicist is not falling off the knife
edge and most of the time we're all on
one side of it or another so the most
interesting things they're not that's
maybe the most interesting questions you
know and we're not even addressing like
the meaning of life you know I'd rather
know what the meaning of life is and
what's inside a black hole well yeah
okay there's lots of questions we don't
there's lots of questions we we don't we
don't address the most interesting ones
are the ones that or the most important
ones what what I meant by that were the
ones that
are both interesting and and and doable
and
uh yeah I think that's pretty good good
I'm glad that you're glad that we can
stick by the advice so Andy stromager
thanks so much for being on the
blindscape podcast okay super fun shot
[Music]
la la la
[Music]